فَوَاكِهْ .. فَوَاكِهْ fruit
طَعْم حُلْوْ  .. حُلْوْ
طَعْمٌ رَائِعْ  ..  رَائِعْ
فَوَاكِهْ .. فَوَاكِهْ fruit
طَعْم حُلْوْ  .. حُلْوْ
طَعْمٌ رَائِعْ  ..  رَائِعْ
أَنَا مَوْزَةْ banana
أَنَا مُنْعِشَةٌ وَلَذِيذَةْ  وبِالفَوَائِدِ مَلآنَةْ
أنا تُفَّاَحْ apple
يَمْ يَمْ أَنَا شَهِيّ  وأَنَا الفَاكِهَةُ الأَجْمَل
أنا تفاح apple
لا لا لا لا *** لا لا لا لا لا لا
فَوَاكِهْ  fruit
بُرْتُقَالَةْ orange
برتقالة orange
أَنَا نَافِعَةٌ لِلْهَضْمِ وزُكَامًا فِيكَ أُعَالِجْ
أنا بُرْتُقَالَةْ orange
بُرْتُقَالَةْ orange
أنا خُوخْ peach
أنا خوخ peach
بِالفَائِدَةِ أُقَوِّي القَلْبْ  مَا أَجْمَلَ طَعْمِي المُنْعِشْ
أنا خُوخْ peach
فَوَاكِهْ .. فَوَاكِهْ fruit
طَعْم حُلْوْ  .. حُلْوْ
طَعْمٌ رَائِعْ  ..  رَائِعْ
فَوَاكِهْ .. فَوَاكِهْ fruit
طَعْم حُلْوْ  .. حُلْوْ
طَعْمٌ رَائِعْ  ..  رَائِعْ
أنا تِينْ fig
أنا تين fig
بِي فِيتَامِينٌ ومَعَادِنْ  مُجَفَّفا كنت أَوْ طَازِجْ
أنا تِينْ fig
أنا تين fig
أنا فَرَاوِلَةْ Strawberry
أنا فراولة Strawberry
أَنَا حَمْرَاءُ أُقَوِّي الدَّمْ لِي نَكْهَةْ مَصْدَرُ فَخْرِي
أنا فَرَاوِلَةْ Strawberry
أنا فراولة Strawberry
لا لا لا لا *** لا لا لا لا لا لا
فَوَاكِهْ  fruit